hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter 2 of his categories Aristotle
makes a set of distinctions and then
provides some examples that I have found
myself as a student quite confusing when
I first started studying Aristotle and I
have I've seen many many students saying
what is going on here I don't understand
what he's talking about within a subject
predicated of a subject all these
different sorts of possibilities so it's
actually not that complicated and I
think that it just requires us to follow
out what what Aristotle is actually
saying and perhaps it's helpful to put
it into something like this a schema
where we can separate each of these off
in something like a square and say this
this quadrant over here represents for
example in a subject but not predicated
of a subject this one over here is in a
subject predicated of a subject not in a
subject predicated of a subject and then
neither in a subject nor predicated of a
subject and if we if we compare it that
way I think a lot of it falls into place
and it turns out not to be so mystifying
before we look at these four sections
and I don't want to call them categories
because category has a very specific
meaning here that's can
acted with predication what does he mean
by by predicated of a subject or in a
subject so predicated is a little bit
easier to start with let's actually
think about that first the Greek term
here in this work is leg a thigh from
legging which is the word to say to say
something about something else so to say
that this book is thick or that it is
hard bound or that it is green I mean
funny thing to say it's green right
because the book itself this is the book
is not green but the outside of the book
is is green or to say that my tie is
long or that I am I am a man or that I
am tall or I'm middle-aged these are all
what we call predication to say that I'm
in front of the chalkboard is also
predicating something in this case we're
talking about a relation or another way
of thinking about it position so
predication I think is not really that
tricky to wrap your head around you're
saying something of something else or in
Aristotle's terminology we are combining
terms we are we're taking this term and
combining it with this term this tie is
blue hopefully you actually see this on
there there might be some sort of form
of color blindness or maybe you're
watching this on a black-and-white
monitor but but trust me the tie is
actually well it is blue but also white
right because there's little white dots
in there that's that's predicating
that's not that difficult now what about
in a subject so we should clarify this
term subject to begin with when we're
translating the Greek here the Greek is
hoop okay manone we translate that as
subject the subject is that in which
properties or qualities or predicates
you know while predicates can be applied
to it that in which things can in here
because the the underlying
Hoople came in on the subject admits
that but the subject is there even if it
hasn't been given all of these these
properties or things like that so the
thing about substances right think about
you know a book for example book is an
individual substance it's a material
object it's a material object of a
certain sort it's got this very if you
think about a very strange form all
these bits of paper sewn together or
glued together in you know within the
spine and the cover and all that alright
so it can admit of things it can admit
of the greenness of the cover for
example right so Aristotle goes on and
he clarifies by saying by in or present
or found in a subject that's how it's
being translated here all right
he says I don't mean present or found as
its parts are contained in a whole so
we're not talking about like how an
individual page is part of the whole of
the book or the tie is part of my
ensemble of clothing or the finger is
part of the hand and also the hand is
part of the body what are we talking but
he says I mean that it cannot exist as
apart from the subject that is being
referred to so again if we talk about
the greenness of the book's cover or the
whiteness of the books pages yes we can
have green nests in other things for
example in other books we can have the
blueness of the tie somewhere else I
don't actually have anything else that's
blue right here but you get the point
the greyness of the shirt could also
exist in the chalkboard but this
grayness here cannot exist except in
some object you see the difference
between that
grayness in general grayness as you know
sort of a color schema that we could you
know do the RGB for and program into a
computer grayness is actually existing
in something that then you can see
there's a difference there and we can
say this about other things as well and
when we get to the examples I think this
will make more more sense so let's look
first instead of going in the order that
Aristotle does let's actually start with
what's not in a product not in a subject
and not predicated of a subject so this
is what Aristotle calls substance Lucia
and this would apply to primary
substance that is individual things book
names a whole bunch of substances this
book right here
names a particular book we destroy this
book there's plenty of other copies out
there I could purchase one but it would
not be this book this human being that
is named by Gregory Brian Sadler and
there may be more than one Gregory Brian
Sadler out there I know there's a lot of
Gregory Sadler's out there and you know
maybe maybe there's another one with the
same name but but let's just pretend
that that's not the case
we're talking about this guy right here
right or this hand now I could get maybe
a substitute hand you know in some
sci-fi scenario there's something like
that it would not be this particular
hand so we're talking about he has the
example of that person or that horse
that human being or that horse now why
is that not in a subject and not
predicated of a subject okay let's start
with not in a subject this is a subject
this is this is substance individual
substances are the subjects that provide
sort of the basis for all these are the
things to either be in or predicated of
it's not predicated of a subject we do
use the name for example Gregory B
Sadler of this guy right here but what
we're doing there is we're not
predicating me of me but what it is to
be Gregory V Sadler
we're just saying this name is used to
denote this object here you ask me hey
what's your name
Gregory B Sadler right there we go but
you're not taking me and predicating me
of some other subject now you might say
well wait a second what if dr. Sandler
gets into a bus or a train isn't he then
in another subject namely that
individual mode of transportation he
hops in his car and drives around right
well yes in a sense but that's a very
accidental connection and you know
Aristotle would be willing to grant it
he just he just say well really what
your predicating is you're saying that
dr. Sandler is inside of something
there's there's a location or relation
or something along those lines right and
and it's not really anything essential
to say well dr. Sanders in this this car
but so I'm not in a subject that
particular person or horse is not in a
subject it is a subject it's not
predicated of a subject let's move on
then to this category something that's
not in a subject but is predicated of a
subject I mentioned that you could use
my name Gregory B Sadler and predicate
that of me that guy over there is dr.
Gregory B Sandler right that's that's
predication right there but your
predicating the name of the thing in
that case or if you say Gregory B Sadler
is wearing a blue tie today something
that won't remain true for very long
okay it's a true statement at the point
that I'm shooting this you are
predicating something of me
the substance that is this individual
person he talks about predicating human
being of that human being or we could
say horse that horse or we could say
this is this meaning this object is a
book meaning this we call this thing
book or we call this Aristotle's
categories meaning this is a copy of the
prints that we call Aristotle's
categories we're predicating something
of this this particular subject even if
we call this a green alright we're not
we're not necessarily saying that green
is of the substance of it or anything
like that
we're just saying this is something that
appears green it's something we call
green or are you may as well just call
it white and black and white as well
because that's also the colors of it
you're not asserting anything about the
particular greenness that is in hearing
in the subject it was merely predicating
the word green as a descriptor of this
so hopefully that is clear and you see
the difference between these right
subjects we don't we don't predicate
them of anything things are predicated
of subjects including the name of the
subject or the the kind of thing that
the subject is its qualities its
quantity we're gonna get to all that
sort of stuff in another video where we
talk about the categories per se now
let's move over to here this this part
so this is the opposite it's in a
subject but it's not predicated of a
subject here's where it starts to get a
bit more tricky
Aristotle uses the example a bit of
grammatical knowledge so you know
knowledge that we have inside of our as
we say metaphorically inside of our head
and I suppose it you know if we think
that the brain is where this is
happening it's not really all that
metaphorical where is that exactly quite
sure we're inside the head inside the
structure of neurons it is but it is
still inside the head right so a bit of
grammatical knowledge inside of your
head inside your mind
that's not a subject itself although
perhaps maybe you know we could stretch
it out and it could be but Aristotle
doesn't treat it as a subject instead
it's something within a subject what is
the subject your mind you essentially
are the subject or that other guy who
has the grammatical knowledge who's
going to share it with you
particular a body I'll use the example
of the particular greenness of this this
book this greenness which is caused
presumably by some dyes or you know
processes that that created this all of
the kind of green I'm not sure what
shade exactly that corresponds to that
is in this object this greenness cannot
exist except in a physical object now
other instances of that greenness can
exist in other objects right or perhaps
even in a color you know scheme that we
have say on the computer how do you know
what's that color well you have to look
at it and now it's there in the computer
screen alright or if you say well here's
a swatch well it's there in that's what
the swatch is then a subject that that
that greenness is inside or with it let
us say so that's more clear I hope at
this point what it means to be in a
subject now let's talk about the
combination where something is in a
subject and it's also predicated of a
subject here's where it gets a little
bit more complicated and and I think it
could trip you up very easily because
Aristotle said uses the example of
knowledge being present to the mind
which looks a lot like this right and
then he says it's also predicated of
grammar so what does Aristotle mean here
he doesn't just mean knowledge as
grammar although that's where it's
heading
he means knowledge per se knowledge per
se is present in a mind right whatever
kind of knowledge it happens to be
boatbuilding dancing the the Charleston
you know etiquette about which fork goes
where what whatever sort of thank you
you want right it sits in a mind I mean
you could also say well the knowledge
could also be in a book what we mean
there is that we've you know
consolidated it in there or maybe it's
on Wikipedia right but it's still in
something it's it's somewhere we also
use the word knowledge of grammar we
predicate knowledge of grammar you know
very much the same way as we might
predicate animal of human being grammar
is a particular type of knowledge right
human being is a particular type of
animal and we can use this term grammar
also as a kind of generic term to mean
the grammar as knowledge that's inside
my head the grammar that's in in your
head that allows us to both of us be
able to talk to each other and you can
hopefully make sense out of what I'm
saying right and then when you put your
comments hopefully I understand them so
knowledge is being used be very careful
here in two related but distinct ways
it's being talked about as a thing which
then can be in a subject but it's also
being talked about as something that we
can predicate of something of a subject
or of something else that could be in a
subject like the grammar grammatical
knowledge that is in the subject right
so this one is a little bit tricky here
hopefully you see the difference between
these there may be some things that
depending on their context could seem to
jump category
not categories jump these
classifications or straddle them but
this is this is what Aristotle is
talking about at the beginning of the
categories and so hopefully now this
distinction is a bit more clear for you